IN THIS NICE APARTMENT
THAT HER PARENTS ARE PAYING FOR.
SO THEY'RE SITTING AT HOME,
AND SHE'S READING
IN HER BATHROBE WITH HER FIANCE.
AND THEN THERE'S, LIKE,
A KNOCK AT THE DOOR.
[dog barking]
NO. CUTIE, IT'S OKAY, IT'S OKAY.
IT'S FAKE.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE DOGS.
QUIET!
QUIET, QUIET, QUIET!
SHE OPENS THE DOOR.
LIKE, OH, CAN WE HELP YOU?
OH, WE RAN OUT OF GAS MONEY.
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THEY ALL CAME POURING IN.
AND THEY'RE LIKE, AHH!
AND THEY BEAT UP
THE MATH TEACHER,
STRANGLE HER,
AND TAKE HER CAPTIVE.
BRING HER IN A VAN
OVER TO THEIR HEADQUARTERS.
SHE'S BLINDFOLDED.
SHE'S GAGGED.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S GAGGED.
SHE'S DEFINITELY BLINDFOLDED.
THEY PUT HER IN THIS CLOSET.
IT'S LIKE THE SIZE OF A CLOSET.
AND SHE DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING, REALLY.
SO IT'S 57 DAYS
SHE'S IN THIS ROOM.
SO FINALLY, ONE DAY,
THEY LET HER GET OUT
OF THE CLOSET,
AND THEY TAKE OFF
HER BLINDFOLD.
AND SHE LOOKS OUT
AND SHE SEES ALL THE PEOPLE.
SHE'S LIKE, OH, MY GOD,
YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL.
OH, WHO ARE THESE PEO--
LIKE, YOU GUYS LIKE--
YOU'RE MY MOMMY.
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY
WHAT STOCKHOLM SYNDROME IS.
THAT WAS THE SYMBIONESE
LIBERATION ARMY.
"SYMBIONESE" IS NOT A WORD.
IT'S--THEY KINDA MADE IT UP.
THEY'RE NOT THE BRIGHTEST PEOPLE
IN THE WORLD.
NOW YOUR NAME'S TANIA.
AND THIS IS YOUR NEW LIFE.
AND SHE'S LIKE...
OKAY.
[upbeat rock]
AND THEN THEY DO
A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND SHE PUT THE BERET ON
AND A MACHINE GUN,
AND SHE'S, LIKE,
ALL WITH THE S.L.A.
SO SHE STARTED RECORDING
THESE AUDIO TAPES
AND SENDING THEM
TO HER PARENTS.
MOM, DAD, I'M OKAY.
BUT I NEED YOU TO FEED
EVERY POOR PERSON.
THAT ENDS UP BEING
LIKE 300,000.
$300 MILLION.
THEY'RE ALREADY STUPID.
LIKE, THEY COULD NOT COUNT.
AND THE HEARSTS ARE LIKE,
WE DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH MONEY.
WE'LL GIVE YOU $3 MILLION.
WHATEVER, DUDE.